all right who do I believe do I believe
younger who says we may not have a deal
today do i believe the markets are
powering ahead its gains all around or
do i actually believe Angela Merkel
whose tight-lipped but who's a little
bit more I guess cautious on all of this
well I think that we are going to get a
deal it may not happen today but the
details again are not important and you
know I mean we've been having exactly
the same conversation once after month
after month and I think I'm very
optimistic i'm relatively close to
offering to eat my hat july one
television if there isn't a deal of some
kind of the other i'm not doing that
quite yet mark it's hard you Angela
Merkel does not want to be the person
who presided over the fracture of the
URL and that's what tsipras is banking
on as hands explained it's not about the
money it's not about Germany losing a
billion URLs a year in the event of
Greece leaving the URL it's about the
project itself being fatally wounded
wanted to prove that it's not
irreversible and it's a pretty good
gamble it's it's it's a pretty good
gamble if you're the Greek Prime
Minister and guess what it's paying off
we're still having talks they haven't
they haven't cut the ropes yet the ECB
is continuing to fund what must be an
insolvent banking system given the
outflows that have been reported um so
so far Cyprus is winning that the
brinksmanship and if anyone's gonna
blink it looks like it would be Germany
and do you think even I mean I know you
both expect a deal and I understand that
it's she doesn't want to be her legacy
to be the transferor that kind of
oversaw this breakup of the euro zone
but the same time will you understand
from insiders that she's fed up right
her patience is at the limit if we don't
have anything today and I know Sony you
say well we'll have it at the end of the
week but actually how crucial is it if
we're not gonna have capital controls
that we get something today well I think
it's not all that crucial to be fair I
mean first of all a default that delay
in payment to the IMF is not actually a
default in any sense of the word and
traditionally the IMF has almost always
given a 30 day grace period and the
reason that christine lagarde said that
it may not happen is again putting
pressure so both sides of putting as
much pressure as possible on each other
but at the same time the ECB has gone
from weekly to daily
monitoring an extension of the ELA to
give the sense of urgency so basically
you sense the end game is nigh and the
end game still looks like a compromise
we're to be fair I mean despite what you
said about you know mrs. Michael
blinking in the end Greece has actually
moved far more from the initial position
of Sarita compared to what the
institutions had put on port so Greece
has really really sort of come probably
three-quarters of the way and the even
the EU is not so stupid so as to break
up the eurozone on the basis of a
hundredth of a percentage of EU GDP
that's the only difference that remains
one hundredth of a percentage of EU GDP
and we are not going to see the collapse
of the euro zone over that piddling
amount of money mark my words but this
is not I mean I know even the EU is not
that stupid is it because actually
there's a point where maybe politicians
say well let's you know let's go through
with this if they want the catharsis
argument has legs and it certainly given
the attitude of the German Finance
Minister Wolfgang show blur I would bet
he's got a strong feeling the Euro would
be stronger rather than weaker without
greets the problem there is that the
unintended consequences might kick in
and that's it that's a massive gamble
the other point on the deal is Obama
said has to be ratified by national
parliaments someone has to actually
write the check the goal is to Greece if
it wants to avoid not paying on june the
30th and it won't have been ratified by
national parliaments you're gonna see a
lot of financial engineering at that
point because they'd rather not miss
that payment even if technically they
kill it it's gonna be messy no matter
what Sony do you think that the markets
are you know all guns blazing today
because they think that there will be a
deal or even if there's no deal there's
the ECB so how will get more QE well I
think there's there's a great fatigue in
the markets you know we've we've seen
this game so many times and it does seem
given that President Obama has weighed
and given that geopolitical
considerations have started to wane
given that it's become extremely clear
that it's mrs. Merkel's call and as
we've discussed before you know mr.
schauffler has been in favor of kicking
Greece out since 2012 but it was never
his call and now
become crystal clear that this is a
political decision and the more
political this decision is the more
geopolitical consequences are taken into
account the less likely that the market
expects there to be aggressive why is
the US so concerned because Jack Lew
last week sounded very very concerned
about it even more concerned than I
think many Europeans are is it all to do
with your old Allah is you just
concerned the euro will collapse and
that will hurt us x I think it's always
reward a political issue for the u.s. I
think it's it's the security dimension
more than anything else and I also know
for a fact that very senior people like
NATO for example have been very
concerned about what the implication the
security implications of this would be
so it's geostrategic more than direct
financial or economic consequences